(light music)
- When I look at a map, I see opportunity.
- [Narrator] This is Patrick Quayle.
He's a global network planning executive
(Patrick speaking
indistinctly on background)
at United Airlines
which means he decides
where the airline flies,
when it flies, and what
type of aircraft it flies.
- I can talk about planes forever.
- [Narrator] Quayle has more
than 15 years of experience
planning flight routes.
- You can also see Denver,
the aircraft flying west.
(Patrick speaking
indistinctly on background)
- [Narrator] So he's here to
explain how that process works
and how an airlines route
system affects travelers.
- There's two main network structures.
There's hub and spoke, and
there's point to point.
- [Narrator] United and
other legacy airlines,
like Delta and American, use this model.
- The way the hub and spoke works,
you have Denver as a hub
and then you'll have flights
from, let's say, Lubbock, Albuquerque,
Jackson Hole, and Las Vegas.
These are the spokes;
the spokes cities all fly into the hub.
The passengers then change airplanes
and then those flights disperse
to different cities across the country.
- [Narrator] Here's what that
looks like on a real-time map.
- In Los Angeles and San Francisco,
you can see traffic going out to Hawaii,
traffic intra California,
and then traffic coming up
across the upper northeast.
(Patrick speaking
indistinctly on background)
- [Narrator] Here's what that looks like
on an aircraft schedule.
- And the color depicts the hub.
Aircraft number six, for
example, it's flying from Korea
and every time it's in red,
it's coming back to San Francisco's.
- [Narrator] The spokes are
designed to feed travelers
into the hub around the same time
to make connections
easier and more efficient.
But this also creates periods
of very high and very
low volume in the hub.
- You look throughout the day,
and it'll go peak, trough,
peak, trough, peak, trough,
and that drives cost
because you have a lot of
activity and you have no activity.
- [Narrator] Hub and spoke
is a more expensive model,
which is why legacy airlines
are the ones who typically use it.
Low-cost carriers, by definition,
try to keep costs low.
- In order to support the hub,
you need a couple different things.
One, you need the assets,
which is the gates,
the clubs, the lounges,
the terminal space.
The second, you obviously
need the employees.
- [Narrator] Another reason hub and spoke
is designed this way is to feed travelers
into larger aircraft
for long-haul flights.
- We'll have aircraft like
this 737 flying into our hub,
connecting to this large 350-seat aircraft
that's gonna fly to a place
like Frankfurt or Johannesburg.
- [Narrator] Quayle says
that by connecting in a hub,
travelers have more options
when it comes to destinations,
flight times, and re-booking
in case a flight gets canceled.
- Often, many hub-spoke carriers
have service to multiple hubs.
And so if there's a weather
incident in a major hub,
we could fly you over a different hub.
And then once you get to that city,
you can be re-accommodated on
the network out of that hub.
- [Narrator] If there's an
issue with the aircraft,
hubs also typically
have maintenance spaces.
- We can simply tow it to the hangar
and tow in a different aircraft up
to continue the flight on.
- [Narrator] To pay for
all this infrastructure,
Quayle says legacy carriers
charge a higher ticket price.
- Meaning a better
product, better experience,
and hoping people will
pay more for that product.
- [Narrator] Most low-cost airlines
like Southwest, Spirit, and Frontier
use a point-to-point system
which works like this.
- You'd fly from San Antonio to Amarillo.
In Amarillo, that aircraft might
turn and go to Kansas City.
And from Kansas City,
it might go to St. Louis
and then down to Jacksonville.
- [Narrator] Southwest says
one benefit of this model is that
because planes don't have to
connect through a major hub,
the airline can offer more
nonstop flight options.
- If you live in a smaller community,
take San Antonio for example,
there's a low cost airline there
that has 20 different cities
they serve out of San Antonio.
Whereas if you're flying a legacy carrier,
you're gonna need to connect
in a place like Houston,
Dallas, or Atlanta.
- [Narrator] Though
point-to-point carriers
don't have official hubs,
they do have larger locations
that facilitate many of their connections.
They usually have one fleet type
which simplifies their operation.
- They only have to have one
crew and one maintenance team
providing service to
the exact same aircraft.
The downside to this, though,
they're only able to serve
mid-size and large cities,
and they can't fly trans-oceanic.
- [Narrator] Quayle says
one of the challenges
with a point-to-point model
is the ripple effect if
something goes wrong.
- If you're flying from
San Antonio to Amarillo
and then from Amarillo to Kansas City,
if the airplane has a problem in Amarillo,
it's gonna then impact the
passengers going to Kansas City
and those passengers getting
on the plane in Kansas City
who wanna fly to St.
Louis and then go beyond.
- [Narrator] Southwest says
if a flight is facing a lengthy delay
or is canceled between cities,
the airline will bring in another aircraft
or reroute travelers to
minimize disruptions.
But some industry experts
say the point-to-point model
may be one reason Southwest
struggled to recover
from severe winter storms last December
leading it to cancel over 16,700 flights.
Southwest has held that
the model wasn't to blame.
According to Southwest,
a point-to-point model
brings in more redundancy
during weather challenges
allowing the airline to get travelers home
as quickly as possible
through other routings.
All airlines update their route networks
throughout the year.
These are the factors Quayle looks for
when deciding whether or
not to add a new route.
- What's the nonstop demand?
So how many people are in the major city
going to the other city?
How much support is coming in
from all the different
spokes into that hub
which provide feed to that new
flight that we'd be adding?
- [Narrator] If no other airline
flies to that destination,
that's another reason to add that route.
But Quayle says he also adds service
to places with a lot of competition.
(airplane whirs)
- In London Heathrow, for example,
we've increased service from
New York to London Heathrow
to create more time
channels throughout the day
for a consumer to go
between New York and London.
- [Narrator] Partnerships
with other airlines
also play a role in choosing where to fly.
- The reason we have as
many flights as we have
into Frankfurt and Munich
is for their ability to
connect onto Lufthansa
to go into Eastern
Europe and North Africa.
- [Narrator] To add a route,
Quayle says airlines have to go
through a government regulatory process
which prevents other carriers
from piggybacking off their
idea, and the process can take
anywhere from a couple
months to a couple years.
- I hope people appreciate the complexity
and all the planning and work
that goes in behind the scenes
so that when they show up at the airport,
they can get on a flight to
go from point A to point B
and have it operate seamlessly.
(light music)
The funniest misconception
people have about me
when they hear network planning
is they think that I work in IT.
(Patrick and camera crew chuckle)